for the introduction
so I'm Rosita and it's a great pleasure
to be able to present here so today I
will be sharing two perspectives how to
mitigate privacy issues in
cyber-physical systems and first day
what are several physical systems there
are a combination of computational unity
and the physical environment so we have
some computational unit interact with
physical environment it gets information
from the sensors and it also has these
controllers that can control the
environment so indeed actually a lot of
most exciting innovations today are
cyber physical systems
examples include smart buildings smart
grid and smart transportation systems
all those systems are very different
from one another but one thing that they
have you common is that they are all you
know theater regenerated ok again take
amount of data so actually so but you
know there is a problem about privacy so
for the first billion that I showed here
it is considered the greenest building
in the world it is office space of the
conducting firm Deloitte and this
building is packed with twenty eight
thousands of sensors and it generates
the data you know all the way from
temperature energy usage to ovens the
coffee machine used to be filled up so
as you can see this is a lot of data
although some of the data may seem
harmless like temperature and energy
usage but what I want to show you next
is that actually we can easily infer
some private sensitive information from
those seemingly harmless data so here is
example this is a snapshot of the smart
meter data taken from a household and
you can see that it is very clear when
this family is taking vacation and when
this family is at home so actually as
Mindbender can become the best friend of
burglars so they can look hazard data
and he said the lab of occupancy at home
and then the other determine you know
when to
send teams to breaki so so how can i
really go about these issues so i want
to share some challenges for you know
dealing with these privacy issues in
cyber physical systems so firstly are
those systems the demand for accuracy is
really or for data utility is very acute
because the systems are oftentimes if it
equivocal for example in small buildings
we use sensor data to determine when to
Tehran's air conditioning and we cannot
afford to you know making the office
space too hot or too cold so we really
want to push this curve of privacy and
the utility trade-off and also so we
have seen that the system is often in
closed loop and the data is used in your
control application so how can a really
model data unit here in this context and
as we have seen before
some data are actually seemingly
harmless but if you assume that attacker
has some ability to do some inference
then there will be a lot of privacy
sensitive information come out so how
can really model Padilla's in this case
so in stock I will be sharing two
perspectives to solve this problem and
really to optimize the privacy agility
trade-off so the first that year that I
want to lead through is that we want to
follow this principle that the data is
actually owned by people and individuals
through to be able to control the
dissemination of the data and any
entities that try to that can benefit
from data should properly compensate the
data owners so the first idea is that
how can we really pay people for using
their data so when it comes to the
payment a natural question is that how
can we guarantee fairness this is a very
important question and secondly I will
introduce an approach is to model
privacy laws model data utility and
therefore formulating explicit
optimization problem to solve for the
optimal privacy mechanism so let let me
start with the first work the data
valuation work so I want to give a
special
for all my collaborators without whom
this work wouldn't be possible this is
really a collaboration between this
amazing people from berkeley eth and
also you are you see so I want to study
the devaluation problem in the context
of machine learning so imagine we have
some individuals who contribute some of
their private data which are images so
in machine learning we want to trim
machine learning model based on those
data and the hope is that when the model
system you know some unseen data it can
predict its label very well so in
machine learning it is natural that we
know that the training data is not used
in isolation they have correlation and
they have interplay with each other
so the natural idea is that we can
actually model machine learning process
as a collisional game where each data
contributor at each people who
contributes their private data is a
player in the game so if we have n data
contributors then there will be n
players in the game and another
important component to formulate a
collisional game is so-called utility
function so what is your TA function it
really defines a score that measures how
useful is a subset of collisions so in
machine learning context it can be the
test the accuracy of prediction
confidence for let's say for the
regression test it can be our score
score so it is really flexible and
context dependent and so we can actually
use this framework to consider a lot of
machine learning tasks
you know pay us to a cooperative game
yeah so then the meaning dollar question
is that how can we actually attribute
the benefit created from abrogation of
the data to each data contributor in a
way that is fair reasonable so here we
adopt a huh you have predicted so here
we adopt a concept from car video game
theory it's it's called shared value so
it defines a way of distributing the
profit of a relation of all players and
it was first proposed by this Nobel
prize-winning economists Lloyd Shapley
in 1950s and what is interesting is that
it is mathematically proved to be the
only distribution that satisfies a
correction of desirable properties and
it turns out all those properties has
very close connection with some
real-world interpretations so which I
will talk more later so that's that has
first look at what his definition of a
bad look it is every actually very
intuitive and very simple so you here is
a utility function and as different a
defines a subset of players so I capital
ah here is just a notation for all the
players in the game so if there are n
players it will be 1 to N and as I said
as is a subset and essentially the scene
in the bracket it matters what is a
marginal contribution of player I when
it is added to some subset in the
correlation right and the shar-pei value
if you look at its form it defines the
average a marginal contribution of a
player so it essentially matters how
important this player to this collation
of other players so in terms of its
properties the first property is
satisfied is that its group rationality
it says that it's a shared value of each
player will add up to the profit that he
generated by the circulation of our
players
so what his cargo crash analogy is
because any rational group of players
would expect who shares a field of the
game instead of part of them and the
second property is very interesting it
is kind of connect to the fairness of
the payment so it says that if two
players I energy the energy are have the
same utility when being added to some
subset in the collection then they will
have the same shared value and the
second is saying that if some player I
have the interim actually have the same
have zero introduce your room you tell
any difference when being added to a
subset then it's chaplet value is zero
so this is really seen that if we
consider group of data contributors what
the matters to your data's value is not
their names and the value only depend on
like how useful their data are or hole
what is how much is your contribution to
other set offer players and the third
property is called additivity it means
that if we have two utility functions
and we want to compute the share value
on their twitter functions then it will
be equal to the share value on their
each should hit functions where it is
interesting is because in often times
you know our data is used for multiple
applications it will be used for
multiple times and for each application
we can calculated by a YouTube function
and this is seen that if if our data is
used used for multiple times since the
values that we deserved from those
multiple applications is equal to the
value that we receive from each
application so actually we are not the
first one who think about share value
and usually value for values of private
information actually impact to 2001 and
this is there is a seminal work by
Greenberg who try to use a separate
value to value is upon the private
information and then the returns that
there are some follow-up works but the
common challenge
that have faced by those works is that
shabby value it is extremely hard to
compute and and also like fancy and the
for that reason of those works are
focused on some stylist example super
sharp value is about it can be
analytically derived so to see why it is
very difficult to compute we can see
that we can go back to the definition of
sharply value you can see that in order
to compute it we need to evaluate this
marginal marginal utility or were all
subsets of the players in the collation
and there are essentially financial
number of them so computing champey
value will require exponential time and
if it considers the shape if value is
the machine learning contacts
it will be even harder because even
evaluating this utility function is very
hard because it will consider to be the
testing accuracy it requires that who
Treena a new model also a new subset of
data and then calculates a testing
accuracy so in summary it will be very
hard to compute a shared value but on
the other hand there are some
opportunities and to calculate that they
have value if they put it in the machine
learning context let's say if we
consider some specific use a function
associated with machine learning models
let's consider a very simple ones a 10
years neighbour classifier so let's
define the utility function to be the
testing accuracy of a nearest nearest
neighbor classifier namely we wanted a
to be 1 if the labor of it has the point
agrees with the label of its nearest
neighbor and 0 otherwise so let's say
this is the training point at the test
point is a black dot and you can see the
red dot will be its nearest neighbor so
if they consider a subset as unless you
want to compute the share value of this
player I we can see that we if we want
to evaluate the marginal utility of the
player I it will be zero because the
utility is completely determined by the
nearest neighbor and Eddie I to the
subset s
Changez utility so that means that if
they restrict our scope to some
particular machine learning models then
this Utena function will be accurate
zero and we have some hope to reduce
exponential complexity to some
reasonable and practical time so here is
the most surprising result that we got
from this work essentially if we
consider the youtaite function
associated with Kenya aristocracy first
we have a little work also studies occur
in Kenya snipper regressor so if you
consider to be the key nearest neighbor
prediction competence and then all we
need to do is simply just as sorts the
training database according to its
similarity to a test point and then use
this recursion here so all the
computation objective value can be
accomplished in log in time which is
officially extremely fast so we use this
technique and go to some very large
database and see what is the value of
different training points so on the red
and left hand side you can see this is a
test image and the right hand side is a
top value training points for a
particular test image and you can see if
the test image is this is nature and all
the you know top value training points
will also belong to nature class so this
is in that shadow value if you use data
value to measure the importance of
different ringing points and those high
value put possibly automatically
correlate here is a test point okay so
this is for K n but if we have
considered some generative functions it
will be still hard to compute a shadow
value so the state-of-the-art approach
is to actually using this sampling based
approximation so to illustrate the idea
we need to go back to the definition of
shared value here we consider a
alternative definition objective value
it's at a commission to be equivalent to
the previous one that we discussed so
essentially the shopping bag of
I is equal to its basically looks at
other permutations and the calculate
what is the contribution player I to its
to the players proceeded in the
permutation and average over all
permutations and the if we consider
permutation to be a random variable you
can see that the chaplet value is
essentially the expectation of the
marginal utility average across also a
random permutations so this inspires us
the algorithm to compute up to
approximate the Shapovalov which is to
use a sample average to approximate this
expectation so the d-pad ours am is like
this for we have some random
permutations of training points drawn
here and for each random permutation
with basic computers or marginal utility
of each training point and then the
average is a marginal contribution
across different permutations to talk
more about the you know the complexity
of this algorithm we need to formalize
what is our notion for approximation
error so here we consider a oximeter of
share value as had to be the epsilon
approximation to the true shape eval us
if the our infinity norm between the two
between the estimate and the truth shall
be value is bounded by epsilon with
probability at least 1 minus epsilon is
really close to the definition of an
absolutely the other differential
privacy and if we use this ya do have
question okay so so if they use this
approximation error notions and you can
actually use some simple down the to
derive that this algorithm request n log
n model retraining to achieve epsilon
approximation error so this is the
state-of-the-art result for
approximating the Shakya value then the
question is that can we do better
yes
so how do you imagine like actually like
using these two I have a motivation agus
was paying people for their their data
but I guess at training and you're using
the the test points to determine how
much to each each of the training points
is work but I guess we often like you do
the training and then know in the future
what things this model will be applied
on so how do you imagine and at what
stage and using what test points we
decide how to that is a great question
so you machine learning pipeline you
always have this you know you I crack
some data you're often hams or divide
the data into trainee and testing you
want to you know sufficiently it has the
performance of the machine learning
model before the poetry into practice so
we can just use those test data to it
has a problem at the performance of the
machine learning model and yeah rephrase
for these questions just a little bit if
you if you get data over time you can't
do the permutation just because you
don't have everybody over there
distribution of possible sort of
incremental e at the beginning so it
does matter who comes first
I think this is a interesting expansion
that we need to consider in the future
so Rena we only consider this you know
offline a machine learning and online so
you know very interesting interaction
that's yeah yes ran our only concern is
training data it probably needs some
more thought about how can we do it at
state as well yeah so let me go back my
slides so we have talked about this city
of the art approximation algorithm so
the question is that can we do better
than that so it's a you know I think
about what is a state of the art
approximation algorithm it's so it
basically draw some random permutations
and then computes a marginal utility of
each player independently so then the
question is that can we do some you know
using samples drawn sleigh and consider
the information sharing between
different random samples so here let's
see we have two random subsets drawn
from the training dataset so if the
image is shaded it just means that these
two samples are not selected by by this
random subset so let's say we have two
random subsets you can see these two
subsets have one happen to have one
image in common so if they evaluates the
utility of these two random subsets and
it happens to that of this who run a
subset achieve high utility so this is a
very good indicator that this image that
they have in common has very high
sharply value right so this means that
we can actually there are some
information sharing between definition
samples and the can we really make use
of it to develop more sample efficient
algorithm so the answer is yes so here
is our ism we can actually encode the
apparent occurrence of four different
training sample using this binary
variable and we consider this utility
difference and our idea is really to
design the sample distribution so that
they'll see you generate a difference
actually expectation you could choose a
p-value difference and if we can ask me
is the share value difference very well
then we can you know use a small amount
of four samples to estimate the share
value of a particular training point and
then we'll be able to recover the share
value of the rest of the point so let me
tell you the mean result so basically
this new sampling based approach that
employs this idea of information sharing
Territory absent your approximation to
the true self evaluate only sublinear
number for a model of training
recall that to the sphere of the art who
curse the super linear in log n a model
training and this is really a large
improvement I will we have a large
number of a large number of training
points so they are yes question
when you train the model like you if
you're trying to evaluate the
contribution of one training point
presumably you need to get a really
accurate evaluation of the model
accuracy is there some way to you know
to not not do that to like train the
model only approximate like roughly or
something just to get a real you know
some kind of estimator of the
contribution also so in this so I think
I depends on how your formula is a
utility function so if your utility is
really like the accuracy of a model if
you train two best
then we will need to treat every model
to the best in order to calculate the
capital u but if your formulation for
utility allows them you know error
during training or allows an errors in
terms of prediction then we can probably
change model subject with an arrow and
then compute the shock value
so I guess I'm just like just if the
contributions are I don't know what one
of our n even once you've trained the
model just evaluating the classification
error to that level of precision
requires a huge number of model
evaluations yeah that's exactly the
problem so so as I said so we have if we
have a care nearest neighbor algorithm
it will be very fast because we don't
need to train the model so if we
consider like keeping your network as
you said it would be very hard to even
evaluate is the testing accuracy so what
are we doing the experiment is that we
have given your network what we can do
is that we use the deep features and
replace the last layer is okay and so
that we can you know make yourself was
the first algorithm associated with scan
to compute the value of different
opinion points yeah so you only trained
the representation was
so yeah so here are some other ideas to
make such a p-value our evaluation
morally patient so here is one so we
plot this is based on empirical
observation from our experiment so we
plot the shattuck value of different
training points in a database of size
1,000 and you can see that almost all
the training data have similar shape and
you except a few of them so this is
really in scene that actually the
champion burial has this sparse
structure if we consider a large
database so then the idea is that how
about using compressive sensing which is
very renown idea to recover the signal
from noise environments if you have only
very few if the signal has the Espace
structure so here we combine compressive
sensing with sampling and get these
results that we only require log log n
number of model retraining in order to
compute the chaplet value if the
underlying value is sparse so let me
introduce some more ideas so if they
consider a learning algorithm that is
stable so it is stable meaning that the
learning algorithm isn't very sensitive
to the removal or addition of a
particular training plant and why
learning algorithm is increases because
it has some probable generalist and
generalization error bounds and also
it's a incorporates a large class of
commonly used machine learning models
like linear regression some and all
learning algorithm with proper
regularization so our memories are they
seen that if the algorithms the learning
algorithm is itself is stable then we
can just uniformly assigns it value and
it already gives us a epsilon 0
approximation so some more ideas to
accelerate the computation objective
value so because the shock value
requires you know evaluation of this
marginal utility a difference and
if it just do it naively then we need to
retrain the model in order to evaluate
his you tell you the difference so here
is the heuristic to actually
approximately the difference based on
this idea of influence function and it
was developed by it actually it was
proposed last century by uber and then
and then redeveloped by this paper in
2018 and they tried to computers and so
try to use the influence function to
approximate the effect of removing one
training example and that see how the
performance changes so we use the
influence function as a heuristic to
compute this utility difference and it
will give us a speed-up in terms of to
compute the Shappy value and another
idea is that some sample value looks at
every subset in the collation so how
about we just look at the largest subset
without looking at every one of them so
apparently this can also seller it's the
process of computing computing the
champion value but it no longer
satisfies properties that we discussed
before simultaneously so there is a
trade-off between you know the rigor of
the data evaluation mechanism and the
computation efforts that you use so yeah
here are some results we compare refers
to look at so what is approximation
error of different ideas that we
developed and so x-axis is the true
shape a value which is produced by the
staff the art proximity algorithm and
the y-axis is our estimated based on
different ideas and you can see that our
new sampling algorithm and if a user use
the utens function heuristic it can all
like
estimate the true shape a value of arey
well and if the we use Kalyan
because the utility function changes
then it will have some discriminative
from the true shape a value based on a
lottery through question and if we use
largest influence largest set influence
then
of course there will be even larger
discrepancy and on the red hand said it
is a random part and on the very top we
can see that the state-of-the-art
sampling algorithm performs very bad
when we have training we'll have a lot
of training examples and our new
sampling performs that it better and if
we use more heuristics than we can get
more acceleration and the kinship value
is of course the further part is 1 up to
now
so here is a plot just to show you that
so the chaplet value actually coincides
with our notion of value so we actually
do experiments which try to divide the
training set into two part one I want
probably just keep at it is and the
other part we add some artificial noise
into the data and you can see as more
noise added into the data the share
value of those noisy points will be
lower so essentially this is just saying
that just confirms with our intuition
that Chevy Belair is a fairly good
notion for data value so just a summary
so we have introduced framework and some
formalization of data value and we have
discussed a repertoire of efficient
algorithms to compute the chaplet value
and we are actually currently building a
system theater marketplace in together
with Stanford Hospital so the idea is
that so we want to pay the patients for
for their data so there will be some
buyer whose payment will be distributed
to different patients and our shared
value did evaluation mechanism is
actually implemented on this data
marketplace and ran now we are doing
this clinical trial and for future work
so we really need to consider how can we
encode the personalized privacy
preferences into the state evaluation
framework because right now this
evaluation is solely based on the
payments to each user is solely based on
how much their data how useful their
data is for some specific machine
in task but some people might feel more
conservative about privacy's and the
others so how can we deal with that and
also we really need to develop more
efficient algorithm for broader class of
machine learning models like gradient
boosting and so on so forth so as you
can see there is there are more
questions than answers so this talk is
merely I mean to invite discussions and
more efforts towards this direction so
how much time do i I would just like
quickly go through the rest of the talk
so it's a second part I will and
basically introduce some approaches to
models of privacy and the utility and I
will illustrate a through example in
smart buildings
so let me directly go to the problem
that we are trying to solve in smart
buildings so in smart building we have
some sensors that capture occupants
environment and those measurements will
be used to adaptability controls a
heading eight reactors means healthy
validation air conditioning system in
the building but there is recently
published attack are seen that we can
actually recover the occupancy recover
the location trees of different people
from those occupant environments the
idea is that if the attacker knows owner
of different office then he can
associate the change of occupancy to the
location trees of different people so
that is the problem that we are trying
to solve so what we do is that we
propose this new notion of inferential
privacy so the idea is that we
considered attacker and there are some
private data and populated has at the
attacker can see before seeing the
public data he has some cost associated
with inference about the private data
and after see the private data his
influence is updated and the this
difference between two inference called
really characterize how much privacy is
leaked through the publication of the
public data so if the cause is logarithm
loss then this privacy decayed it
becomes neutral information
so in the rest hug we will be using this
mutual information to characterize
privacy laws and the information privacy
is different from differential privacy
in the sense that if we have very good
at a certain model then I will give your
very explicit characterization of the
privacy laws so so in our problems and
the private data will be is a location
and public data will be the occupancy
and we are trying to solve it algorithm
trying to solve a problem that search
how to minimize the privacy laws subject
to some control performance constraint
and we'll evaluate this control
performance through simulations and it
turns out to be a linear programming and
can be had sufficiently soft so let me
just give you the result so so this is
just to show the privacy utility
trade-off for different mechanisms so if
it we compare with fixed schedule where
you don't need to collect any data but
of course we have high control cost on
the other side you can create you know
highly accurate data but of course the
privacy loss is very high so what this
plot shows is that we want to have this
trade-off between privacy and utility
and you really have two options
why is to you know replace your sensor
by a cheaper sensor that is equivalent
to adding some multinomial noise to the
occupancy environment and this part is
really showing that you can do better by
solving this optimization problem and
achieve a better Paris utility trade-off
so some other works in the space that we
have been doing is that I have talked
about how to you know he stored this
sensor data in order to guarantee more
privacy
but since the separate vehicle system is
a closed loop system can we even like
her you know the gesture control and
incorporated privacy laws as part of the
control objective so we have this very
interesting work try to study how can we
jointly design control and sensing for
privacy in some physical system and we
have some interesting results in that if
they have linear Gaussian system then
the problem of control design the
problem of privacy mechanism design can
be completely decoupled and that will be
efficient if we want to
those mechanisms and we also have some
work try to identify the redundant data
for a particular application so user
interface' prama
I want to briefly go through some works
that is happening in dance group so most
of them are considering how to really
deploy differential privacy into
impractical scenarios this one is about
how can we design differently private
convex optimization problem and this is
a paper to be appearance in this year's
Auckland conference and the contribution
is that we have this convex optimization
that leverage of the share of optimizers
and doesn't require any hyper parameter
tuning order to achieve differential
privacy and there is also a large skill
empirical study that compared different
coax optimization problems that he our
that have differential privacy
guarantees so another project called you
at this project is really trying to
approve automatically prove differential
privacy in practical systems it achieved
this goal by actually design a
domain-specific programming language the
last project I want to mention in dance
group is chorus which is similar to what
my code talked about so this kind of
designs a bridge that facilitates adding
privacy into some query
ng and it can be useful by some young
experts so yeah to summarize I have
introduced perspectives we start from
you know how to value data and how to
make it is reasonable it is fair and
most importantly make hits computational
tractable and also goes through some
method who you know model privacy laws
and the utility and also some works in
dance group and we're dead I will send
you for your attention and I'm happy to
take any questions
[Applause]
can you take a little bit more about how
you model the adversary in terms of sure
so in this case we have a very explicit
a tosser model which is taken from
another paper so they study how to
attack the how to recover the location
trace from the let me go back to this
how to have the location trace from the
occupant environment so what they do is
that we use a factorial mark of hidden
Markov chain and the hidden state will
be the location trees and the
observation is occupancy measurement so
they basically do this inference onto a
graphical model to recover the location
location trace the hidden state so we
have a very clear model of attacker in
this case yeah
there is a lot of resemblance fingers
pathetic
[Applause]